okay let's see we've got so many people
holding maybe more than ever before
let's try the 705 area code who's
calling today from 705 just as input low
hold on a second hold it what's your
name where you calling from
okay Larry your connection is is one of
the worst we've had you're not talkin
into the phone through like a crinkled
piece of paper are you it's it's
marginally better what's your question I
was just wondering what like I'm
Canadian
I was wondering why it seems that
Americans think that if you get a
single-payer health care system that
your insurance through your employer
would go away we have it here in Canada
it covers a vast majority of things that
don't get covered by our single-payer
well I don't think everybody does think
that I mean yeah listen so there have
been questions asked as does private
insurance get made illegal if you get
single-payer or something like that and
most people say no allow it to exist it
could cover optional procedures it could
cover cosmetic procedures it could cover
procedures at different facilities than
maybe the single-payer system but dental
and things like dental and eye eye where
like for things like that right that's
exactly right so it's just I don't know
I just seems to be I guess maybe it's
the kind of trans drama in the argument
that people would lose insurance that
they have through their employer well
Lewis lose versus not need are two
different things and there's certainly
no question that many employers would
simply stop even offering to subsidize
some kind of for-profit plan if instead
there was some kind of single-payer plan
available that that's all true but I
think the the point is private insurance
if you don't outlaw it it will still
exist and it will still be available it
might cost more it might not make sense
to pay for it but it's still something
that would exist
I guess maybe Legislature should look at
ways of having it so that it can exist
to cover those things that wouldn't
would
you don't even need to look at it I mean
it exists and as long as you don't
outlaw private insurance it'll it'll
continue to exist listen I'm gonna let
you go because the the connection is
just I don't know what it sounds like I
don't even know what it sounds like but
I appreciate the phone call and we'll
continue to inform people on that issue